Major breaking news as the state of
Maryland is freaking out and has just
filed a major brief with the United
States Supreme Court trying to stop the
Eva Marie Gardner versus Maryland case
from being heard by the Supreme Court.
This is a big deal, folks, because if we
win the Gardener case, it is the next
major break toward nationwide concealed
carry because it speaks to the right or
lack thereof under the Second Amendment
of the ability to carry one's gun as you
travel. It's a big deal, folks. Let's
break it down when we come right back.
[music]
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
fourbox of Der Proud American Gun Owner
Constitutional Attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Bar and I'm
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Two years running.
Thank you. 2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards.
All right, folks. This is a big deal,
folks. Big deal. So, there's a Supreme
Court case right now up on Cert.
Petition is pending by a woman named Eva
Marie Gardner against the state of
Maryland. Now remember, I've explained
to you good facts make good law, bad
facts make bad law. That's why we don't
like the Supreme Court cases of Raheem
and Hammani. Bad facts make bad law.
Here we have the polar opposite
situation. We have a very sympathetic
plaintiff, i.e. a criminal defendant in
this case. We'll get to that in a
moment. on very sympathetic facts. The
case involves Eva Marie Gardner, who is
a resident of the state of Virginia who
was traveling through the state of
Maryland with a loaded gun to visit her
mother in Pennsylvania. This is
understood. This is acknowledged by both
the state of Maryland and by Iba Marie
Gardner, the petitioner here, seeking
cert from the Supreme Court. while she
was driving on a highway in Maryland,
she was allegedly run off the road and
hit, there's no debate, there's an
accident here, and the gentleman, if you
can call him that, uh, who ran into her
car, approached her car, as she said, in
a threatening way. She took her gun out,
which she had a Virginia license, and
that's key here, folks. She had a
concealed carry license and had a
concealed carry license in Virginia for
many, many years. She took out her her
licensed firearm
that she hadn't locked up in the
dashboard and she showed it to the man
approaching her car. A man by the name
of Khaled Binafi. Khaled Binaf was the
man's name. He den he stopped
approaching the car. He got back into
his car. At the same time she called 911
and said that someone had just tried to
run her off the road. There was an
accident. She needed help and she had a
gun and was protecting herself with it.
A police officer showed up, looked at
the situation, and recognized that she
had a gun and noticed that her gun,
while licensed in the state of Virginia,
she was in the state of Maryland at this
time and did not have a Maryland
license. As a consequence, he
effectively cited her, arrested her, and
she went to trial, raising various
Second Amendment arguments, and was
found guilty of possessing a firearm in
the state of Maryland without a Maryland
license.
Now, that's what happened. She then
sought an appeal through the Maryland
court system all the way up to the
Maryland Supreme Court, I believe, and
that was all denied. And now she has
sought cert from the United States
Supreme Court arguing that she had a
second amendment right to have a loaded
gun in Maryland while she was traveling
through Maryland from her home state of
Virginia where she had a license to
visit her mother who lived in
Pennsylvania
where I believe she was also allowed to
have a gun.
So she argued that she had every right
to have that gun loaded in Maryland as
she was traveling through.
The argument of course that under Bruan
she obviously has the right to have a
gun in public for self-defense. She has
the right to carry it. That's what the
right to bear means. The right to keep
means the right to possess a gun. The
right to bear means the right to carry a
gun in public for self-defense purposes.
And she was carrying a gun in Maryland
for self-defense purposes. In fact, she
actually used the gun for self-defense
purposes to make sure she was not
attacked by what she perceived to be
threatening behavior of the person that
had hit her car and caused the accident.
Nevertheless, because she was
technically in Maryland with a gun that
was loaded and guess what? They arrested
her and they convicted her. So now she
sought Supreme Court. She's gone to the
Supreme Court arguing that the court
should hear this case on the grounds
that what happened in the state of
Maryland, a state of course, a
government official, government actor,
violated her second amendment rights.
Now, what's very interesting here, and
we'll break down sort of the details of
this in a moment, there's really kind of
two very interesting points here. Big
picture. We're going to go big picture
first, then we'll break it down in a
geeky way.
Big picture is we know as a matter of
plain text you have the right to keep
and to bear arms. The right of the
people to keep and bear arms shall not
be infringed. Because she was carrying a
gun in public in America, the plain text
is implicated. Meaning she had a right
to keep and bear arms at the plain text
level under the Bruin methodology.
Because Maryland says that uh she did
not get a license
and therefore could be convicted. It's
up to Maryland. It's the burden of
Maryland
to demonstrate there's a historical
tradition of firearms regulation
that would justify Maryland insisting
that an individual American with
American with a concealed carry permit
issued by the state of Virginia
traveling through Maryland had to get a
Maryland concealed carry license or a
Maryland gun license. That is
essentially the historical tradition
that Maryland has to show and the burden
of proof is on Maryland because once the
text of the second amendment is
implicated the burden shifts to the
government in this case the state of
Maryland to show there's a historical
tradition that would justify the modern
day gun regulation.
But there's two issues with there's
several issues with the Maryland
position.
First is that there is no historical
tradition of firearms regulation in the
United States that prevents travelers
from being able to carry a gun loaded
and unlocked in case of confrontation
with some form of tyranny. There is no
historical tradition of preventing
travelers from carrying their guns from
one state to another. So Maryland cannot
show there's a historical tradition
of restricting the ability of travelers
such as Miss Gardner here who was
traveling from her home state of
Virginia to her mother's state of
Pennsylvania and she traveling through
Maryland. There's no historical truth in
the United States of preventing people
who are traveling through a state
traveling through a state
from not being able to have their
firearms available for self-defense.
That's one level. Beyond that, there's
actually historical affirmative
evidence, affirmative evidence that
indicates that travelers going all the
way back to even before America was a
country, there was affirmative evidence
in the historical record, that travelers
who travel through a jurisdiction, who
travel through a state, who travel
through a colony,
are actually exempted, they are exempted
from many gun control laws of that
jurisdiction.
So if you're in Virginia and you have
the license to carry a gun in Virginia,
you're traveling through Maryland to go
to Pennsylvania, the historical
tradition of firearms regulation to the
extent it exists at all
speaks to the issue of there are
exceptions to or exemptions from firearm
regulations while you're traveling
through.
Now, if Miss Garner
had stopped at Maryland for like 3
months
and partied and hung out and vacationed
and did all sorts of fun stuff and
looked for a job during the like 90 days
between Virginia and going to
Pennsylvania, then that might give rise
to a different set of questions.
But on the facts presented here and at
trial that gave rise to Miss Garner's
conviction and again as we she was
traveling through Maryland, she was hit
allegedly. She was there was an accident
here. The question is who did it? Uh but
it appears as if based on the record Mr.
Khalif uh being a thief is the
individual that caused the accident. She
felt threatened by him because he
apparently approached her window in a
threatening way after the accident.
But nevertheless, uh she brandished the
one. She showed the gun, whatever you
want to say, and it prevented
potentially prevented her from being
physically violently injured or worse.
We don't know. But she was traveling.
She wasn't hanging out there. She did
not establish a doicile or make a home
in Maryland. She was traveling through.
And that is going to be an interesting
argument for the Supreme Court to
address because even if the Supreme
Court wants to say that if you want to
spend time in another state, you have to
get a license from that state. That does
seem to be a little bit different than
simply traveling through going from
Virginia through Maryland to
Pennsylvania. Now, this is not the first
time the Supreme Court, and I don't
think anybody else has connected these
dots, so I'm going to do it for you and
for the people that litigate these
things. I'm not sure anyone has
connected the dots that I'm aware of
that this speaks very uh closely to the
Supreme Court case
of NaRPA versus the city of New York.
That's right. Not brewing, a different
case few years earlier. Nice versus the
city of New York where the Supreme Court
granted SER on the question of whether
or not individuals in New York City with
permits, homeowner permits, premise
permits, whatever you want to call
those, whether or not they had the right
to travel with their gun outside of New
York City to practice and go target
hunting and target shooting, go hunting,
um go to a different range, all sorts of
things. And the Supreme Court granted on
that and New York State and New York
City mooted out the statute. They
basically changed the statute to mood
out the case. But it does speak to the
issue of guns and the right to travel
with guns under the second amendment and
that's what this case presents. Now
beyond that connection to nice surfer
versus city New York, there's another
interesting thing here and that's this.
When was Miss Gardner pulled over
arrested in this accident? when was she
involved with this uh traffic situation
that gave rise to her being found that
she had a gun in Maryland without a
license.
This occurred in 2021.
and she was convicted in early 2022.
Now, for those of you out there that are
star students of the Four Boxes Diner,
why is that interesting that she was
convicted in 2022 in the early part of
the year? And that is because she was
convicted five months before five months
before Naurupa versus Brun was decided
by the Supreme Court. And why is that
important, folks? Do you remember how
the Supreme Court in Bruin said that the
state of New York's uh law, the
discretionary licensing law, that said
that that the licensing officials had
the discretion to determine whether or
not someone had a need had a need to
possess a firearm and carry it in
public.
At the same time that Brun was decided,
the Supreme Court indicated that the six
other states that had the same sort of
law, meaning you had to go beg for
mother mercy from the state officials to
be able to get a concealed carry permit
to carry your gun in public. Guess what?
One of those states that the Supreme
Court spanked on the P but was the state
of Maryland. That's right. Why is that
significant?
Because to the extent Marilyn wants to
argue
that Miss Gardner had to go and get a
Maryland concealed carry license before
she traveled from Virginia to
Pennsylvania to visit her mother in
2021.
She had to get a Maryland gun license.
Turns out that the Maryland gun
licensing law that Miss Gardner would
have availed herself of to procure
such a license was declared
unconstitutional by Breuan
because of it was a discretionary
licensing regime analogous to New York.
That's right. So, a related argument
here is even assuming today, right here
and right now, to travel from Virginia
to Pennsylvania, you'd have to get a
concealed carry license from Maryland to
do so. Assuming that that is the fine,
assuming that that is constitutional,
assuming that that is the law,
Miss Gardner may still have a way out of
this by arguing that the Maryland
licensing law that she would have had to
apply for or apply through before the
January 2021 accident
was unconstitutional because Bruin said
it was an unlawful discretionary
licensing regime in violation
of the second amendment.
Very interesting turn of events. The
point is in my view this is the kind of
sympathetic fact pattern, a sympathetic
second amendment rights claimment, Miss
Gardner sympathetic set of facts. She
used a firearm potentially to prevent an
assault after a man uh allegedly or
definitely there was definitely an
accident. That's a fact. There was an
accident um that allegedly was caused by
the man who allegedly threatened her and
she used a gun to prevent a possible
assault. And she called 911 legally
called 911, told 91 she had a gun, let
them know, did not hide any of this,
explained in detail why she had the gun,
what she did with it, why she was going
to Pennsylvania, all the above. This is
a very sympathetic fact pattern that may
very well get the attention of the
Supreme Court. And we know it already
has because remember it was the Supreme
Court after Miss Gardner filed a prosay
on her own behalf petition that the
Supreme Court ordered ordered the state
of Maryland to file a response which
tells you at least one Supreme Court
justice is very interested in this case
and I don't blame them. It's very
sympathetic. I should also note that
Maryland's position here is that number
one uh the trial record was not
developed on the second amendment. But
that's BS because as you know the
historical record of what the second
amendment means is not an adjudicatory
fact where like whether or not you went
through a red light. It's what's known
as a legislative fact which means it
speaks to the history of a law. The
history of the constitution. You don't
need to develop a trial record for that
or have experts. As we've talked about
before, there were no trials on or
experts in any of the Second Amendment
cases to date. None in Kitano. There was
a trial, but not on the Second
Amendment. None in Bruin, none in Heler,
none in McDonald. And you get the point.
None in Raheem, none in Hammani. So,
yeah, there's no need for a trial record
on the history of the Second Amendment
because it's a legislative fact, not to
be confused with what are known as
adjudicatory facts, which is again
whether or not you went through the red
light, whether or not the doctor
committed malpractice. Uh these kinds of
factual questions. Uh that's not what
analyzing the Second Amendment is about.
It's about the history here. They also
say Maryland also argues in their brief
today that there's no split of
authority. Um maybe yes, maybe no, but
there's certainly been a lot of
discussions around the question of
whether or not you have the right to
travel through the states, including the
federal law, the free uh the firearms
owner protection act enacted in 1986, uh
that allows you to carry guns from one
state to another through other states
that don't allow you to have guns if
it's locked up. separate from the ammo
and you know the drill. So obviously
this is not like a new issue because
Congress even addressed it. Then
Maryland says that there's legislation
pending of a nationwide reciprocity
bill. But again just because there's a
bill pending is very speculative uh that
it will do anything. And even it didn't
do anything. It would not say Miss
Gardner who was convicted uh in 2022. So
even if you passed reciprocity for
concealed carry nationwide today, guess
what? would not do anything to mood out
her case because she was convicted under
a different set of laws. And of course,
they're trying to say Breuan does not um
deal with any of these issues. But as
I've just covered, there is simply no
historical tradition of firearms
regulation in the United States going
back to the founding that prevents
travelers from being able to go from
point A to point C through state B or
jurisdiction B. And again, the
historical tradition to the extent it
existed is actually favorable to Miss
Garner because there were exemptions and
exceptions for travelers uh from a lot
of these gun control laws going all the
way back to even before we were a
nation. So to the extent you look for
historical firearm regulation tradition
here, it actually favors Miss Gardner.
Uh and it's not just silence speaks
volumes, it's actually affirmative
evidence in Mark Miss Gardner's favor.
Anyway, there you have it, folks. I'll
put a link to the Maryland brief below.
And yes, if we win this case, it is
another step toward the possibility of
nationwide concealed carry. Every brick,
every precedent, every step, every
island we capture is one more step
toward the island of Japan in World War
II, if you understand the metaphor. It's
another step toward fully vindicating
and restoring our Second Amendment right
to keep him bear arms in all respects.
Okay, there you have it. I hope you
enjoyed today's episode. Make sure you
follow me over there on XBox Diner.
Don't forget to subscribe both to
YouTube and Ramon. I'll talk to you
again real soon here at the boxes time.
[bell]
>> Orders up. Table 2 A.